احس بعمال الكردستاني همم غير موجود في
سوريا والعراق حتى نقول بانها يستهدفون
لحزب العمال الكردستاني لماذا دائما يتم
تشبيه اكراد سوريا واكراد العراق بانهم
عناصر لحزب العمال الكردستاني وبحسب
التقارير التي
عقبت الغاره الجويه التركيه همم غالبيه
غالبيه الشهداء هم من المدنيين يعني ربما
هناك همم عنصر او عنصرين او ثلاثه من قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وخمسه عشر عشرا من قوات
النظام اذا هم ليسوا من عناصر حزب العمال
الكردستاني الموضوع كل ما هنالك تركيا همم
تستخدم همم اسم حزب العمال كردستاني
كتشماعه من اجل توسيع الرقعه الاحتلال في
المناطق همم في شمال سوريا كونها احتلت
المزيد من الاراضي والان همم تحتاج همم
الى حجج اخرى لكي ااا توسع منه فوده هناك
وفي السمات يلا طالما حظي المقاصرون
الاكراد بغض النظر طبعا عن تسميتها تختلف
من بلد الى بلد حظو بدعم كبير بجانب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هل الان امم
هناك تغيير الوضع على الارض وبالتالي يصعب
بالتالي صمود هذه القوات المقاتله في
سوريا وايضا في العراق
ان المجتمع الدول وعلى راسه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وحتى تركيا نفسها كانت
تدعي بانها تدعم القوه التي تحارب الارهاب
المتمثل بتنظيم داعش الارهابي ووقتها قامت
بفتح حدودها لتشمرجه كردستان العراق بان
يدخل من الاراضي التركيه الى كوباني لكي
يؤذن وحدات حمايه الشعب كلنا يعلم وقتها
كانت ال- ال- ال- داعش تسيطر على مساحه
شاسعه من الاراضي السوريه وكانت على
متاخمه على
الاتراك مباشره لماذا لم تقم الدوله
التركيه وقتها
بمهاجمه همم تنظيم داعش الارهابي التي كان
من المفترض ان تحاربها كونها تدعي محاربه
الارهاب ايضا في المناطق التي تحتلها
تركيا الان معظم المجموعات المسلحه
الموجوده هناك تحت اسم الجيش الوطني هم
بالاساس كانوا عناصر في تنظيم ده عشان
الارهابي همم تحرير الشامه التي بالاساس
جابت النصره موجوده في مناطق المحتله
تركيا اذا البعر الارهابيه هي موجوده في
المناطق المحتله تركيا
هل تتغير خريطه التحالفات على الارض وهل
هذه التحالفات الجديده الكنب الفعل ذلك
حاصلا ياتي على حساب المقاتلين الاكراد
على حساب الاكراد بشكل عام
انا دائما اقول
داعش كسرت وتحطمت امام وحدات حمايه الشعب
ومؤخرا اصبحت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
لانها تظلم كل مكونات المجتمع السوري هناك
الان تركيا تدخلت بشكل رسمي كانت داعش هي
التي تحارب يعني تركيا في الخلف كانت
تدعمها
العديد من التقارير تؤكد ان تركيا كانت
تدعم داعش وكانت ربما تدعمه عسكريه
وبالسلاح ايضا الان تركيا دخلت الميدان
بنسها كونها رات بان الجماعات الاسلاميه
المتطرفه لم تستطيع همم
اسقاط او المشروع الكردي التي تسميه تركيا
بالرغم بان هذا المشروع يعني الذي يزور
المنطقه يعني لا يستغرب من المحللين الذي
يزورون المنطقه منطقه شمال شرق سوري او ما
تعرف الان بشرط الفرات
الذين يدرون المنطقه
النسبه ال- ال- العظمى هم من مكون العربي
وليسوا اكلات فقط قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
نعم عماد ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه لكن
60% منهم من همم العرب وهناك اشورين هناك
ارمن هناك تركمان هناك مختلف المكونات
الموجوده فيها لكن تركيا تتحجج يعني همم
لو كان همم
تفجير اسطنبول من قبل شخص يعني بالرغم من
ان وسائل الاعلام التركيه اكدت يعني ان
همم
احلام البشير هي همم تم تدريبها من قبل
جماعات اسلاميه الا انها تسر وتؤكد بانها
حكم العمال يعني هم من قاموا بتجنيدها
وقامت بهذا الفعل السياسيه